nous revenons ce n'est pas de cette
enquête policière et nous découverte
pourrait aider à connaître des
déplacements de cet inconnu et son état
de santé
des pistes de plus pour en fait
l'identifier grâce à votre collaboration
peut-être enquête sur un des plus vieux
cas de personnes non identifiées au
québec où allait-elle d'où venait-elle
tout ce que l'on sait c'est qu'elle
s'est effondré dans ce sous bois
[Musique]
son squelette s'est retrouvé à la morgue
quelques années plus tard
[Musique]
je les gardais un vain mot et c'est
jamais auparavant la morgue et de
montréal n'avait gardé un corps aussi
longtemps je m'étais attaché à cette
heure très haut niveau qui va nécessiter
un teint de de travail de toute l'équipe
plan faute d'identité
ce corps n'a jamais été réclamée pour
l'équipe entière à 16 h 30
cette petite et chaque oui j'aimerais ça
pour mettre un nom dessus
puis il trouvait la famille ou si le
coroner le docteur paul dionne a décidé
avec regret de fermer le dos si à
l'automne 2009 gtalk et de celles
apportées étaient dire c'était d'une
certaine façon parce que je pense que
c'est un peu exceptionnel
le squelette a finalement été enterré
ici à longueuil en banlieue de montréal
dans cette section du cimetière réservé
aux gens que personne ne réclame ici pas
de plaque pas de pierres tombales un
numéro de lot seulement les enquêteurs
eux l'avaient surnommée madame victoria
[Musique]
il
et
donc c'est ici
que vous avez reçu l'appel ou sa peine
initiale ce qu'on va trouver un crâne ce
cas unique a piqué notre curiosité
à notre demande la police décide de
rouvrir le dossier de madame victoria si
on la plaint si c'est parce que son
squelette a été retrouvé sur le terrain
de l'hôpital royal victoria montréal à
deux pas du centre ville ce qui à
première vue pouvait sembler une affaire
facile à régler s'est transformé en une
énigme complexe le 13 juin 2009 dans le
stationnement numéro trois du royal
victoria
une infirmière trouve un crâne derrière
sa voiture l'hôpital alerte
immédiatement les policiers
un des policiers qui ont vu que c'était
grave tous les ans
cette figurine sur ma claque à réparer
et remonter puis celle à qui l'on trouve
en haut chez papables
mais on est à 2
conscient de ce magnifique ou moins
on va voir si la pente ce qui est normal
de voir que le recruteur se détacher et
puis ça a roulé jusqu'en bas
l'état du squelette les couches de
feuilles qui le recouvre font dire aux
enquêteurs que la mort remonte à deux
ans soit à 1999
et alors qu'on voit ici c'est sûr qu'on
le pont ar gall sur le statut de
véhicule
et puis on sort mais on peut comprendre
pourquoi que les gens n'ont pas vu un
sentiment de randonnée danois jeppe
adoptant monde ici le dépôt de 200
syriens de darb défraîchi trois hausses
d'impôts à charge mais ce qui surprend
davantage les policiers ce sont les
vêtements que portent les squelettes une
chemise et un pantalon d'hôpital il a
besoin d'un point pour nous tous de
l'intérieur c'est cela la liberté pour
mon petit de la capitale a tout de la
terre aussi dessus
mais si des vêtements qui sont chez eux
aussi
il peut
décomposition du corps de l'intérieur
ici on note aussi une chemise et un
pantalon associe habituellement au
personnel médical
il trouve également sur les lieux une
paire d'espadrilles pour hommes de marc
ayrault cours
un soulier bon marché qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui c'était quoi votre première
premier geste au premier appel aux
premières et d'un jeu de vérifier avec
une liste de personnes spain on vérifie
voir si ça peut correspondre avec des
personnes qui payent disparu on avait
fait aussi des résultats on a vérifié
s'il y avait des personnes qui a
remporté deux super help table et on en
avait pas les policiers font la même
chose à l'hôpital général de montréal
situé pas loin de là même résultat
nous avons tenté à plusieurs reprises de
joindre ces deux hôpitaux
on a voulu voir avec eux qui pouvaient
porter ce type de vêtement madame
victoria est elle une infirmière un
médecin
une préposée où une patiente qui
auraient fui l'hôpital
personne n'a voulu commenter cette
histoire pour eux l'affairé classée mais
qui est donc madame victoria que faisais
tu es là cet endroit entre du
stationnement très achalandé chaque scan
est certaine cette année ce soir on
avait confié ce dossier étrange à la
célèbre anthropologue judiciaire et
auteur de romans policiers
l'américaine kathy reichs nous l'avons
rencontré à son bureau au laboratoire
médico-légal de montréal
j'ai fait l'année
j'ai pris
offrez vers 25 mes yeux d'ukraine
l'ordinateur me dis que c'est un white
fumel c'est une dédicace que les
personnes ça c'est le mot
ça s'est fait mal elle est
définitivement fini invoquait des
ossements éparpillés les cheveux un
dentier et une soldats c'est tout ce qui
reste de madame victoria dans ces cas-là
à l'escalette avait beaucoup de
ostéoporose et aussi beaucoup de
de la retraite j'ai vu beaucoup des
éducateurs éducatrices de l'âge avancé
la femme de race blanche aurait plus ou
moins 60 ans son squelette ne porte
aucune marque de violence pas de traces
de sang mike fisher pas ma spécialité
c'est les eaux ce que je regarde ce sont
les détails
une personne meurt et que ça ne laisse
aucune marque sur les os je ne vais pas
le voir
exemple par exemple si quelqu'un meurt
empoisonné poignardé par suffocation
s'il n'y a pas de marque sur le
squelette je ne peux rien voir
le sergent-détective j'ai raté lui
écarte la thèse de l'homicide
le squelette a été découvert près du
stationnement numéro 3 qui est située
entre le pavillon principal du royal
victoria et le halo mémoriaux l'ale
psychiatriques on regarde plus ce côté
que d'al amana m'avait-elle talent
et puis en crise et pierre parti et
malaise latent s'effondrer dans montagne
puis par la ciotat décennies le docteur
paul dionne conclu dans son rapport que
la mort était déterminé pour lui madame
victoria ne peut être une patiente on
n'a retrouvé aucun bracelet d'hôpital
sur les lieux qu'est ce que quelqu'un
fait avec
au pays des pantalons le type salle
d'opération
tout suggère que ces problèmes est
quelqu'un du personnel
[Musique]
comme les recherches ne mener nulle part
les enquêteurs ont décidé de faire appel
à l'artiste judiciaire de réputation
internationale
michel fournier nous sommes allés le
rencontrer au quartier général de la grc
à fredericton en 2003 il a réalisé une
reconstitution faciale de madame
victoria à partir du crâne et des
données recueillies par cathy rage
une première au québec madame victoria
elle est en fait avoir un visage un
capable de capturer les proportions du
visage l'emplacement des éléments du
visage les yeux le nez la bouche on peut
pas changer au niveau de la structure
arsenault de base pour demander de
l'aide pour identifier cette personne là
on essaie de garder l'expression la plus
d'une passé car je suis impliqué à nous
aussi c'est que tous les autres moyens
traditionnels de résoudre les néo l2
d'identifier cette personne là ont
échoué
voici à quoi pourrait ressembler madame
victoria c'est lors d'une conférence de
presse à montréal en 2003 que son visage
est dévoilé au public
c'est presque impossible de capturer la
ressemblance d'une personne humaine
ce qu'on essaye de faire ici aujourd'hui
c'est tout simplement de donner une
ressemblance à la victime pour que
quelqu'un a quelque part dans le public
soit capable de dire oui
cette personne si ressemble à quelqu'un
que je fais deux ans ou trois ans que je
n'ai pas vu cette affiche circule dans
plusieurs hôpitaux de montréal
personne ne reconnaît cette femme le
mystère persiste mais l'appel à tous lui
semble donner des résultats
suite à la publication au moins 26
informations font le tout validé ce à
quoi des gens qui disaient je pense je
la connais ou oui je la connais
j'ai déjà vu quelque part c'est dans ce
coin là me semble on fait des
vérifications
j'ai eu une information d'un château que
j'ai eu l'information un peu partout
mais c'est des gens qui comme le
kamouraska qui m amène tes caresses ici
n'a pas vu le crâne de madame victoria a
permis une reconstitution à ses fidèles
des proportions du visage
mais de quelle couleur était réellement
ses yeux brun bleu
comment étaient ses lèvres minces
charnue plusieurs personnes croit la
reconnaître
mais une piste s'avère plus sérieuse que
les autres
après la pause la piste de kamouraska
priscilla michaud avec 14 ans lorsque sa
mère et disparus
je suis venu à le rester en famille
d'accueil chez morrow s'est adressé aux
blessés qui étaient beaucoup de blessés
il
[Musique]
les enquêteurs mettent le cap sur
kamouraska deux enfants croit avoir
reconnu leur mère l'aurait toilettes
disparu en 1993 à l'âge de 47 ans nous
nous sommes rendus dans la région de
kamouraska
alors que si je vois ça vous nous parler
de votre mère l'aurait toilettes comme
elle l'était physiquement elle était
bonne de 9 était blonde est cité en
blanc les derniers rallyes qu elles ne
recueillent pas savait pas qu'elle parte
presse a été mesurée 4 puis en tapant
était commencée plus grosse que moi
aussi quand même que magma tigre os 7
les cheveux longs westerlo comme si là
pour elle puisque avait les cheveux
frisés
au goût beaucoup évolué angeleo
mouahahah ce soit priscilla michaud
avait 14 ans lorsque sa mère et disparus
qu'est ce que vous savez que votre mère
les derniers temps ben moi j'ai su lui
donner à leurs essais
entendant famille d'accueil il ya chez
marie moreau à sa tv après six blessés
qui étaient beaucoup de blessés parce
que tu avais beaucoup nous en garde à
vue parce qu'on a été fait de placer
comment donner des gages à ces jeunes
merci
lauret toilettes habitait dans cette
maison de chambres de sainte-hélène de
kamouraska le 7 septembre 1993 et serait
allé chercher son courrier
puis serait reparti vers la maison on ne
l'a plus jamais revu
[Musique]
madame oro sa logeuse l'avait déjà
entendu parler de la possibilité qu'elle
disparaisse un jour si jamais que le
service social puis faisaient du trou je
faisais du trot ainsi un jeu pareil
jakarta dit vous allez avoir banalisé à
me retrouver ce c'est une parole canin
10 points qu'une fois la région a été
ratissée par les policiers leurs chiens
un hélicoptère a survolé les environs
aucune trace d'elle nulle part
la photo de leur étoile est a été
publiée dans le journal le soleil
plusieurs personnes pensaient l'avoir vu
à lyon via québec ils ont dû d'abord
qu'ils ont vu ou la cao lac pohénégamook
à sa taille
la veille la dernière fois qu'il avait
vu il avait vu ou la ka sat retard puis
abandonnée on a eu un look très rock
il avait vu à saint pamphile rayon d'or
laurence moreau demeure sceptique
lorsque nous lui montrons la
reconstitution faciale de madame
victoria peut-être peut-être de la burqa
il ressemble un peu mais non pour moi
c'est pour moi dans ma taille type wales
pour moi dans ma taille non c'est pas
parce que c'est la photo oui ça c'est
elle
cl ça vous êtes convaincu que madame
victoria qu'on a retrouvé à montréal
sévèrement non je convaincu je convaincu
parce que le portrait robot est trop et
trop fréquents quelques saga rambo le
viseur les cheveux c'est impossible que
ce point la ressemblance est tellement
frappante entre madame victoria et leur
étoile est que les enquêteurs demandent
que des tests adn soient effectués sur
le frère et la soeur aînée de précis là
les résultats sont négatifs
malgré ça vous croyez encore c'est votre
grand oui oui oui et même la grille
d'été à des amis qui sont supposés mafia
disent le contraire c'est parce que
j'aimerais moi je veux des preuves que
ses caisses et ses poèmes
les policiers n'ont jamais jugé bon de
lui faire passer un test d'adr ils ont
vite abandonné la piste de kamouraska
l'idiotie de madame victoria et de leur
étoile est sont plus ou moins tombés
dans l'oubli pense à vous emmener jeu
grâce à mes joues tu achètes le souletin
qui auront passé tel savon emporté mais
nouvelle technologie pourrait changer
des choses
notre équipe dans kate découvre qu'à
l'université d'ottawa des chercheurs
travaillent actuellement sur la mémoire
des cheveux les cheveux renferme
beaucoup d'informations sur l'eau que
l'on boit sur ce qu'on mange sur les
lieux que l'on a fréquenté la cleaning
pourrait donc résider dans la chevelure
de madame victoria donc c'est peut-être
la dernière chance de savoir qu'elle est
c'est potentiellement la dernière chance
de savoir qu il
j'ai pas de problème le regard en vo
collaboration toujours à notre demande
le coroner dionne accepte d'ouvrir les
archives du laboratoire médico-légal de
montréal et de cdd mèche de cheveux de
madame victoria aux chercheurs d'ottawa
heureusement plusieurs mèches ont été
conservés durant ces années les cheveux
sont ondulées les séparer est une tâche
très minutieuse qui demande beaucoup de
patience seront t-il trop endommagée
pour les chercheurs nous nous rendons au
laboratoire d'ottawa pour vérifier si
les cheveux peuvent être analysées à
première vue il semble que oui vous avez
que les cheveux et à ces noms vous
pouvoir aller assez loin dans le temps
c'est environ
on n'a qu'une environ un mois par
centimètre alors les cheveux d'après le
l'indicateur l'indication du port de mer
deux cent cinquante deux centimètres de
long puisqu'il faisait que nous pouvons
reculer parce que quatre années les
cheveux pourrait donc permettre de
déterminer où madame victoria a passé
les quatre dernières années de sa vie
les chercheurs sont en train de mettre
sur pied une banque de données sur l'eau
de consommation qui varie d'une ville à
l'autre les éléments d'hydrogène
contenus dans l'eau de consommation se
fixent aux cheveux ils permettent de
savoir quel où nous avons vu de quelle
région provient elle la diète est aussi
inscrite dans les cheveux l'emploi
déterminer si elle a voyagé
s'il était très sédentaire et 6 à 10 ans
travaillés
ça peut nous donner des indicateurs de
ses déplacements ou de ces changements
direct potentiellement pour l'indiquer
soit une maladie ou un déplacement
predica et on sort de cette information
là pour essayer de retracer sa vie dans
les derniers quatre ans de sa vie
bientôt nous pourrons peut-être résoudre
l'énigme de madame victoria pourquoi
s'est elle retrouvée dans ce sous bois
près du centre ville de montréal
et surtout qui est elle
[Musique]
après la pause l'analyse des cheveux et
un nouveau test d'apn permettront-ils de
résoudre l'énigme de madame victoria
elle est restée à des endroits non moins
sept ans doit distraire pendant qu'elle
se déplaçait du nord vers le sud
c'est plutôt quelque chose de physique
qui est arrivé avec sept personnes à la
fin de quelque chose c'est dramatique
[Musique]
l'analyse des cheveux de madame victoria
est plus compliquée que prévu les
cheveux sont très abîmées il faudra des
mois avant d'en tirer quelque chose
une chose qui était bien avec madame
victorieux heureusement ces cas là mes
cheveux épais donc suffisamment de
matériel pour qu'on puisse faire une
résolution quand même assez petit comme
impossible à l'échelle du centimètre en
juillet 2010 gilles saint jean vient
présenter les premiers résultats au
coroner paul dionne et agile raté le
policier chargé de l'enquêté
on peut déjà éliminé complètement
l'ouest canadien c'est certain la
ensuite on voit encore un déplacement ce
qui l'a trouvée est intrigant maddin
victoria s'est beaucoup déplacé durant
les quatre dernières années de sa vie du
nord du québec vers le sud et la changer
de ville
plusieurs fois elle est restée à des
endroits au moins sept endroits
différents
les chercheurs soupçonnent que madame
victoria venait d'une région au nord de
la ville de québec
une personne qui bougeait beaucoup elle
semble pas avoir un pied à terre un
endroit spécifique
elle se déplaçait puis 7 à 10 degrés le
tout en mois 4 mois sept mois elle rame
est revenu à son point de départ ça
c'est certain qu'elle ait toujours
évoluer vers quelque chose mais se
promener ainsi plus moi ça me dit ceci
quelqu'un que c'est une hypothèque et
parvenait à maison sur un puits ci est
en location ben c'était probablement pas
débat et d'un mode victoria le
comportement d'une femme itinérante
nous avons fait parvenir les photos de
madame victoria et de leur étoile est à
différentes maisons d'hébergement sans
résultat personne ne se souvient d'elle
il faut dire que tout cela remonte à une
dizaine d'années je sais j'en ajoute une
information étonnante pour moi je
pensais plutôt quelque chose de physique
qui est avec sept personnes à la fin de
quelque chose assez dramatique novembre
2010 des chercheurs ont tord mais les
résultats finaux de l'analyse des
cheveux et de rencontre est prévue cette
fois ci à nos bureaux
les choses se confirment madame victoria
serait parti d'une régions plus au nord
de québec
kamouraska tombe dans la bande 2 des
données qu'on voit ici c'est impossible
cessé d'en lancer dans la zone non que
l'on considère comme éthanol
effectivement les chercheurs ajoutent
une autre information surprenante elle
serait restée sept mois au même endroit
dans la zone 5
la zone 5 c'est la ville de québec chez
dangereuses qu'elles restent le plus
longtemps
effectivement elle semble pas savoir
déplacer beaucoup essai puis même cette
diète a tendance à se stabiliser un
moment donné pendant qu'il était dans
cette zone points possibles c'est
possible que ce soit ça mais une fois
qu'elle a quitté la région ici on voit
là qu'il ya quelque chose qui est encore
en train d'arriver qui est radical
si c'est quelqu'un qui est malade puis
qui veut pas aller à l'hôpital
ça va être la même chose qui va se
présenter la personne peuvent beaucoup
de cours
personnellement je vois ça comme étant
quelqu'un qui a un problème médical en
escale
ces dernières informations permettent de
dire que madame victoria serait une
patiente
pourtant à l'époque les hôpitaux avaient
vérifié leur dossier et aucun patient ne
manquait à l'appel
aucun problème quand serge suivant la
fin de sa vie peuvent pas absorber très
bien dénutrition ils peuvent plus manger
sera sont nourris par intraveineuse
madame victoria aurait souffert d'un
cancer autre fait troublant
avant même de connaître ses derniers
résultats priscilla nous avait confié
que sa mère aurait appris que la belle
cancer juste avant disparaître s'ils
formaient une mauvaise nouvelle du
meutrier qu'apportait par le fait que
ces finales de l'esea c'est tout ce que
je
[Musique]
je regarde le portrait robot
la personne dans le portrait robot
ohlala santé si cette personne avait
perdu beaucoup de pour rapidement ce qui
potentiellement ce qui était les initiés
possible avoir eu cette information doit
aussi grand que le portrait robot a pu
être faite de deux façons de façon de
façon malade et en santé et en santé
c'est ça je voudrais passer si on peut
faire techniquement rencontré monsieur
fourni pour nous aider à relancer l'
enquête
michel fournier accepte de retravailler
le visage de madame victoria des ions
vraiment changé beaucoup moins à lui
mais je change son expression du visage
le choc où je veux vraiment la main sur
deux beaucoup au niveau des joues et au
menton
beau visage devant tant de similitudes
entre madame victoria et leur étoile est
nous proposons à priscilla de passer
elle aussi un test d'haleine dans un
laboratoire privé
elle accepte oui j'appelle pour avoir
les résultats du test adn dont vous en
est venu à cette conclusion là là
maintenant plus de doute possible leur
étoile est née pas madame victoria la
police compte à nouveau sur le public
pour identifier cette femme dans la
soixantaine qui aurait séjourné dans la
ville de québec et à montréal vers la
fin des années 1990 nous diffusons pour
la première fois le visage d'une madame
victoria malade et fatigué est-ce que ce
visage vous dit quelque chose
je vous rappelle que nous relancions l'
enquête sur madame victoria et nous
avons besoin de votre aide
si vous avez des informations qui
permettraient d'identifier cette femme
et que vous voulez nous contacter vous
pouvez faire sur notre site internet à
l'adresse qui apparaît à l'écran
[Musique]